obsessed you just meet a woman who
really really likes you and you have to
have a woman who is willing to if if you
want a woman if you want a woman to
really really make your life better you
need to have a woman who is willing to
do for you what she has never done for
any man I know that Devin has never done
for any man well
I know that you don't know anything but
I'm willing to bet that it is far more
likely than not that Devin has probably
never done for any man what she has done
for me I don't take anything for granted
including when it comes to my own woman
but that's really how a woman shows you
that she wants to be with you when she
is exhibiting behaviors that you know
she likely hasn't done in the past or
she's only done it with a few guys then
at that point you know she's really a
deal
no I agree I think there's a lot of men
that women have just treated like crap
for a really long time and I think the
tides are turning I think men are
starting to wake up and realize they
don't have to accept this
and I think channels like yours are
really important because like you can he
decodes you know female nature in front
of you in real time and now he's giving
you instead of just talking about the
problem they're giving you a solution
yep yeah that's and you know what's
interesting every quote-unquote red pill
content creator uh goes through we've we
still go through the uh the red pill
phases live in a Living Color when I
first came to YouTube I was you know
[__] ain't [__] and three signs she's
a [__] and four signs she belongs to the
streets and all that good stuff and it's
evolved I mean I started when I was wood
uh this was back in 2014.
um and I'm not the world's greatest
mathematician but my content has evolved
as I've evolved I am dude my message has
never ever wavered it always stays the
same the delivery is is clearly
different but the message is always the
same now do I have some changes in
opinion as far as the operations Within
by Red Bull of course of course you know
with time introspection things that you
learn along the way nobody has all of
the ants answers all at once I'm always
learning but I feel really good about
where I'm at in terms of my mindset yeah
no I think it's the same for women when
we find the red pill because at first
you're like I mean you saw some of my
reactions early where I'm just like well
there's no survey
but then you just start to realize like
like the red pill is talking about how
things generally are and how there's a
lot of big issues for men and it's not
maybe as individualistic because I think
women were so what do they call it
solicism yes solipsism yeah they only
think of things from their point of view
yeah yeah
um also there is someone in the comments
that wants to know how do you get your
woman to keep fit is it disrespectful to
ask
um how do you get your woman to keep we
have a personal trainer that comes to
the house five days a week right but I
mean not everybody not everybody can
afford that here's the thing
um
no no man um if no no if you have to if
you have to how can I put this if you
have to tell your woman hey you're you
know packing on the pounds blah blah
blah blah now don't get me wrong like
Devin there have been times where
Devon's a little puffier than normal at
which point I take action but Devin's
never gotten fat she's never ever ever
gotten fat not on my goddamn watch I pay
way too much money for that but if if
you're with a woman who does not respect
you enough to take care of herself to
remain attractive to you this means
She's Not That Into You And if she's not
that into you there's either something
wrong with her something wrong with you
or both you can't ever you can't talk a
woman into being in into keeping herself
in shape she has to be motivated enough
on her own to stay in shape in order to
stay in order to stay to keep your
commitment here's another thing you want
to know how to keep your you want to
know how to get your woman to be fit is
number one you have to maintain your
value you don't have to be this quote
unquote height you have to you have to
have high value right this doesn't mean
you have to be a millionaire you have to
be a good uh Steward of your money
you've got to be an above average shape
you have to have red pill awareness you
have to know how to handle women today's
modern women as they come if but that
that's that of course that's those are
the prerequisites but your woman has to
know and understand that if she doesn't
uphold her end of the bargain and keep
herself fit that you can and will
replace her if need be women don't
respond to hey baby I would really know
women respond to you flirting with the
hot waitress they respond to other women
looking at you your woman knows when
other women are looking at you and when
other women and the only way to get
other women to look at you is to stay in
shape you know uh you know stay you know
stay fly dress nice smell nice Etc et
cetera if you keep yourself in good
shape then your woman is going to keep
your herself in good shape because she
sees how other women are looking at you
don't tell your woman well listen you
know I could a play Shoot nope show her
and and there might be and I don't I'm
not I don't look at the chat I've got
that I've got that all closed but there
might be people in the chat or the
comments well that's disrespectful call
it whatever you want that is what's
necessary in today's sexual and
relationship Marketplace your woman has
absolutely got to know that you can and
will replace her if she gets fat so the
way to keep your woman from the the way
to keep your woman from Gaining all that
weight in the first place is to make
sure that you keep your [__] together
that's the best motivating factor
Donovan Donovan don't tell them that
that works
that doesn't work David right Devin
there's so many more listens like well
it shouldn't work that way 100 listen
man
um there are um there are a lot of a lot
of my critics and detractors talk about
my quote unquote methods right it
shouldn't work this way you shouldn't do
this to your woman this is immoral
they're blah blah I'm a hundred percent
in agreement with all of them but here's
the thing this is the world we live in
I'm not here talking about the way
things should be I'm here to talk about
the way things are women and the the
environment has changed the environment
has changed and so women have changed
with it if you want to have successful
if you want to be successful women in
2022 you have one of two options either
deal with them as they are or check out
of the of the dating Market all together
I'm not gonna be mad at you if you do
one or the other but wishing women were
back in the 1950s or bitching and
moaning about what's fair and what's not
you shouldn't have to do that no I
shouldn't have to be a [__] [__]
to get respect from women but
unfortunately unfortunately that's
what's required so that's what we do men
were solvers we saw the problem okay
women are hoes and they're no they're
little they're no longer exercising
hypergamy but hope hergamy and if you're
too nice to women they don't respect you
but if you're a [__] [__] they
respect you more so guess what we
adjusted and surprise surprise women are
complaining about it and then still
[__] us so this is what it is men
need to stop acting like victims in
their own relationship for their lack of
leadership
um if your woman is getting overweight
um odds are she's bringing food into the
house that's not healthy
um and if she's bringing food into the
house it's not healthy she's buying it
with the household budget which means if
it's your home that's you that's under
your control
um there have been times where Donovan
has been like okay I want to review the
grocery order or the grocery list or
whatever before you submit it or before
you bring it into the house house he's
opened up the pantry and just thrown out
everything that he didn't want to have
in the house if it was something that
wasn't healthy
um there are there are ways that you can
express your uh not just what you want
but what your requirements
um and it's loud and clear to the woman
now if she's ignoring it if she's you
know just flat out different going
against your your requests
um then obviously there's there's a
deeper issue going on this relationship
that's further
yeah a lot of women will try to hide
their weight gain by trying to fatten up
their husbands as well so if you're
eating lasagna for dinner three times a
week that sounds wonderful doesn't it
she's baking and she's baking chocolate
cakes
and it's great oh yeah my wife cooks and
she you know she dinners on the table
but it's it's unhealthy and it's making
you guys sick
odds are she's going through something
you all need to sit down and figure it
out
um and you know there are ways gentle
ways that you can encourage your
significant other to work out as far as
hey let's go for a walk let's do this no
stop right there give no no no no no no
no no no I got to cut you off no no no
no no no this is bad advice that listen
love you to death sweetheart this is bad
advice listen man yeah it has to be
established from the start I never have
to tell Dev hey honey uh you want to go
for a walk no Devin's Devin's ass is in
there sweating her ass off five days a
week because she knows if she doesn't
she's she's the [__] up out of here and
the reason why she knows she's the [__]
up out of here is because of who and
what I am I'm not special I'm not unique
I'm just I'm I'm on yes I'm I've slept
with more I've slept more women than the
average man yes I make far more than the
ever than than uh than the average man
and those are those are the things that
sort of Encompass who I am but if Devin
didn't feel like it was worth it then
she would not do it there is no reason
at all for you to ever have to tell your
woman hey I'm going to get you an
exercise or gym membership by then it's
already too late if your woman does not
respect you enough to keep herself in
shape to maintain uh to maintain your
attraction to her it's over there is no
let's go for a walk there is no buying
her a Peloton for Christmas she's either
gonna stay in shape of her own accord or
she's not period that's that's what I
was gonna say my butt was him telling
you directly is is going to be the most
effective that's right women women take
hints no women women not only can women
women can take hints they just choose to
ignore them they do they they choose to
ignore the hints and when it's funny
when Deb and I first got together
um it's interesting because Devin's
always had a really nice figure but
we're not getting any younger I tried to
get her to the gym and this and that and
the other so I said you know what I know
one thing Devin's not going to do she's
not going to waste my money I hired her
a personal trainer it's made all the
difference in the world yes it is very
costly it is very expensive it is also
very worth it and I love it
well and what I realized is do you know
the more I like heard about the the
things you you specifically said on your
channel I realized you're giving men a
solution to women that aren't
that aren't traditional anymore yep so
so that's right and I realized that like
being in the west women just were not
traditional it's like as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible